hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey I have to cuff him contain
it don't untie your top rewards your
requests from man named Andrew Terpening
over at our patreon page this comes from
the channel stone mountain 64 this guy
is struggling on YouTube right now only
a million point nine followers loose
that is embarrassing man how old is your
oldest video seven years gosh I mean
we've been doing this for like five
years or something like that and we're
definitely on track we're right behind
you buddy right there this is a warden
defense on-site siege 10 top 10 yep
duck 10 plays
Oh [ __ ]
Shaun sign again fine welcome ladies and
gentlemen to world's best clip of the
week of your host some about 64 and the
Alpha spy
trumpet an L we see your Oh sick it's
hitting the wall bang I see makes it on
objective every Monday and they shall we
featured ten of the best clip sent in
from around the world for you the
audience to vote with the card in the
top right on which go to the original
video have your own send them into the
link in description below always looking
for siege apex pubs in incredible clips
start us out with the Juliet's my father
a Chucky oh you're good Oh stinks so
they're out what it's like to hit every
single headshot the clip cuts out
immediately after gotta save that clip
but even on the runner found the defuser
early on as last up while the drones UPS
is completely staged just watch me
siding great and cleans up the ACE
company for the India's spot sevens got
his own style the plan wow you are so
before amazing wow wow
their bull shark so simple but so
effective and higher enemy team look at
that the reserves bullet beautiful
surrender is the last one alive huh look
at him go
they must have like a gas can spray it
with just enough time pulls off the
defuse those releases on this corner
angle diving straight in for the melee
and in the final pushing Ruiz smoke
finding to kill with just enough time
company for the Gulf spot
Daleks whipping out the p90 if I want to
is go after this damn so terrified one
mag fighting the hate shot yeah mobility
they shot the back nothis it I don't
know what he was doing but Daddo final
Jukes pulls off the clutch place of the
Foxtrot spot over on the test server
this time was warden enemy match white
he's taking the MPX for a spin
he just knows oh are you gonna do some
cool with the pistol no nobody ever does
anything cool with the
it's also 1v5 with a celebration to save
the game those the deep used to bait out
come players again with the company for
the echo spot bandage damn nature nice
oh like that pulls off a damn ace Baca
looking for him behind the desk you saw
him on top of a wrong corner though and
now you think he's not the most well
trained ninja the first night doesn't
work oh the great headshot through the
wall of fire guns Briggs yeah they doubt
this match over time he was
[Music]
even with this whole TV screaming it is
here is the ash that popped up it pulls
off the 1 b5 a Scot awesome company then
Charlie spot Mira on her window but
she's not completely safe
oh no oh no
oh boy it was possible to switch guns
that fast real right no and just store
them no oh look at this replay it's the
first one through the window cover blown
he gets a side angle for the shotgun
blasts off Mavericks Bush in battery
land here's the bug plane going down for
a perfect night Road sauce but earlier
he saw both of them moving there and he
still sees Nomad still up whose laser
sight was coming from there it doesn't
give him a chance to think pushing in
earlier so deeper bubble spot back in
the round nine a match point over time
maestro goes set with that beautiful L
of G logo Marshall ring he cheated on
his wife what
one man which is the entire game catches
the flank matches the one coming up to
the stairs but those are the easy ones
compared to what was coming through the
smoke being pushed here some footsteps
backing off before getting the full
reload and going through the final push
in with the montane blocking the angle
goes to the deep used to pull him off
that shield double kill while he's added
us some of the clutch so and finally
coming in for the outlet spot exposed by
jackal not even on the objective and
health getting cut low this guy sounds
like that Fox therapy
Oh screw that book
nonetheless just through the doorway
through the wall a quick little tap on
the bottle that SMG it's up to your boat
now go with the car to the top right on
winch so these take lips was the world's
best give a like the enjoy of course
subscribe to catch all the latest
content link in description as always to
these amazing players very my second
channel for even more content as well as
come hang with me on stream nude Pacific
every weekday this is still about 64
great YouTube concept idea yeah to
enhance the interactive ways we people
do gaming that's a brilliant I also love
his style because he's reviewing it and
you're going over the skill set and what
they accomplished yes a relevant area
yeah it's brilliant
it gives you this heightened level of
appreciation man it takes some serious
underline the word skill to do that you
know it's easy to gloss over just video
games but no that just takes a lot of
work and that is highly impressive the
idea of the video combined with a
commentary getting us to vote I love
this whole idea that was I was really
impressed and got I thought was gonna be
like some compilations or something and
it was but is more than that well and I
wonder too with the prevalence of actual
eSports in actual sporting environment
like there's eSports on ESPN now like I
wonder if you know players might be able
to get recognized to be is something
like this because like the showcase of
skill you already have that ability in
your online gaming anyway and then
there's the prevalence of Let's Plays
and stuff like that and so do you had to
take all that and make sort of a
competitive but also sort of celebratory
and engrossing little list out of it yes
is pretty cool you know I can beat all
of these though I'm really really good
at video games I think my favorite one
would have to be the Fox Trot bagel Nova
because of like the amount of
celebration the guy oh you could just
hear that level of emotional investment
in what he's doing those guys yes
yes easy you know he was concentrated
like a [ __ ] oh yeah and a point
where he can just focus on the diffusor
there he would have my vote I gotta go
to the video card and go for it because
definitely my vote right there yeah well
that's the other thing too is the
ability to focus in when you've got your
buds and your ears being like or just
keep trying to either psych you up or
like point stuff to you things like yeah
oh that makes it that makes it way more
difficult you [ __ ] up you blame your
friends laughs you sure did you well
actually I rarely think about it because
in video games it's so easy to just like
waste clip after clip but there's one I
can't remember exactly which but there's
really honors like the second one yeah
where the guy did it all in one clip and
it's like wow like that's actual paying
attention to your amaz he's like an
extra skill set in from India 7 superset
95 yeah the 9 spot have your vote
probably yes like damn like Tianna to
conserve bullets that way well done yeah
that's really impressive yeah that's
probably my second pick for that I
probably be there with you on a logical
choice but uh it's for the emotional
side of the guy well yet and and I gotta
imagine once you played at the point
where you can orchestrate as many
headshots and like divide your attention
as much as that like yeah by that time
it's like yes you got to feel the
catharsis of a moment loved it man that
was great all right guys well who would
have your vote make sure to go to the
original video from the channel stone
mountain 64 click on one of those cards
because this is a great video this is
really well done really impressed guys
you can subscribe to the react nation
click that notification bell you like
this video hit the like button you know
all the [ __ ] youtubers say anywho I
want to wrap this up with giving a pitch
in the day shots a man named Andrew it's
happening the man who requested this I
forget you're supposed to be getting
married soon I hope that happens sooner
than later I hope she doesn't leave you
the day of I've seen that happen in
movies and I can imagine that happening
to you vice versa I can see you sleeping
with another person the day of your
wedding I know this is supposed to be a
complimentary shout out and not an
insult one so let's transition guys go
check out Andrew turbines channel he
does let's plays he sent us over a
couple where I believe he's actually
playing Rainbow six as well Rainbow six
siege and he's doing a great job with
editing and a great job with the
commentary love the work that he's doing
and he's just a great really friendly
dude served in the military from Texas
and as handsome as ever he might not
ever come on this channel again simply
because my looks go down significantly
more than they already are when I'm next
to that guy so guys go check out his
youtube channel just type in an
interpreting should be the first one
that comes up see you guys